♪ Розкажи мені,
куди час рікою стрімкою плине. ♪
♪ Хай не наступить завтра,
ніч не схова мої сліди, ♪
♪ зірки стоять на варті,
коли зі мною ти. ♪
♪ Нема шляхів на карті,
повільно крутиться земля. ♪
♪ Зірки нічого не варті,
коли без тебе я. ♪
Ми жили на острові,
ми збудували там ресторан цілий.
[сміється]
Ми працювали, жили там і творили.
Там, до речі, ми побачили велик трьохколісний
і ми вирішили створити такий тут для Івана,
для нашого друга, в якого ДЦП.
Приїхали сюди, замутили цей ровер,
спонсори нам допомогли з ним.
Все, в нас було 300 доларів в кишені
і ми в Лісабон.
Чотири хлопці і машина,
на велосипедах крутим 100 км в день,
приблизно так в нас було.
Да, ось таке от.
Гітарка завжди була з нами.
Коротше кажучи,
я пішов на дискотеку,
на сільську дискотеку:
бум-цик, бум-цик!
На дискотеці я побачив...
На той час, я вже теж
багато де їздив, багато де був.
Побачив хлопець стоїть на візку,
сперся на ті ходулі, танцює.
Ну взагалі йому паралельно,
що там хто дивиться.
Мені стало цікаво, що то за тип такий,
який не звертає уваги на...
Тобто він не соромився своєї інвалідності.
Та й підійшов, познайомився,
і ми так зав'язали дружбу.
Десь через 3 роки... А, і потім він мені розказав,
що в нього є мрія поїхати в Лісабон.
Він сказав, що він хоче
поїхати на коні взагалі.
Бо він займався верховою їздою на той час.
Я сказав, що я допоможу
здійснити його мрію,
але не знаю коли,
поки що я не маю часу.
От, але потім ми приїхали з Ірану,
такі всі заряджені.
І знайшли з Сашком велосипед,
все знайшли.
За три місяці ми організували
подорож в Лісабон:
візи, спонсори, все, сайт.
Все зробили за три місяці.
Я в травні приїхав з Ірану,
а вже 13-го серпня,
якщо я не помиляюсь,
ми вже виїхали в Лісабон. От.
Чотири місяці ми крутили педалі.
Ми взагалі-то їхали туди з метою,
щоб люди роздуплялися.
Це була мета, скоріше,
для здорових людей,
щоб бачили, що люди з інвалідністю
такі ж, як і здорові,
що можна їх активно задіювати
і не тикати пальцем на вулиці.
От.
Ми привезли цей «джульєт»-візок сюди
і зараз от вивозимо людей в гори,
людей з інвалідністю.
Ми в сезон приблизно 15 людей вивозимо.
Тобто ми організовуємо
усе за наші кошти.
Ще ми даєм «джульєтку» всім охочим,
хто хоче, хто має своїх друзів, волонтерів,
вони піднімаються разом з людиною.
Пардон.
Ало.
Добре, то ми зараз під'їдем до тебе.
Давай.
Сашка.
Коли ми подорожували разом з Іваном,
нас випадково запросили
в одну контору, яка займається
з людьми з інвалідністю.
Ми побачили, як у Франції допомагають людям
підкорювати вершини, як вони взагалі це все роблять.
А до того ми колись з Іваном їздили в гори теж,
але на простому велосипеді.
Ми просто взяли Івана, посадили на велик
і штовхали його на Гимбу, здається.
Ми тоді взагалі весь маршрут пройшли з Воловця.
Та, і ці його емоції в горах, перший раз ми побачили
людину з інвалідністю в горах і як він на це відреагував.
Вирішили допомагати тому, що ці емоції
неможливо забути, неможливо передати.
Чому б не почати такий рух в Україні,
щоб людей з інвалідністю вивозити в гори?
— Так?
— Так.
От і вивозим тепер
майже щотижня, якось так.
Хлопець, який не був далі 60 км
від свого села, далі не виїжджав.
Він виїжджає великом в Лісабон!
Першиий час його це
взагалі поламало так,
що я думав, що він більше знов не буде
виїжджати з села.
Але він зараз взявся за себе,
часто виступає на телебаченні,
він мотивує людей, їздить,
робить конференції для людей, розказує,
що не треба сидіти, що треба працювати.
Що не можна складати руки.
Почуваюся зараз як людина,
в якої здійснюється мрія.
Це нейовірне відчуття, дуже дякую всім,
що прийшли сюди розділити його зі мною.
Дуже дякую, вам друзі, всім!
До того я взагалі ніколи не спілкувався
з людьми з інвалідністю.
Я не знав... Я знав, що вони існують
десь там, буває ходять, але так, щоб з ними спілкуватись,
переживати їхні якісь там переживання
чи проблеми, то не було такого.
Ми провели з ним 100 днів...
І ми зрозуміли, що в нього такі самі потреби,
він так само сміється, так само не знаю там...
В них ті самі якісь звички,
ті самі речі роблять, як ми, так що...
Що таке для нас піти в гори?
Просто зібрав рюкзак і пішов,
а вони хіба таке на картинках
бачили десь в інтернеті.
Змінювати суспільство —
це, напевно, хороша справа.
Після наших походів люди
не залишаються такими, як були.
Тобто, спочатку трапляється, що ті,
хто вперше мають якийсь досвід з людьми з інвалідністю,
вони так сюськаються, так здалека підходять.
А після того вже спокійно,
говорять з ними на «ти».
Я загорівся просто допомогти людині,
яка хоче, але не може.
Нам майже всі відмовляли, всі казали:
«Та це нереально, це неможливо з будь-якої позиції:
ні фінансової, ні фізичної».
Але ми це зробили і от...
Той проєкт... Ми не знали, що він розвинеться в цей,
ми не знаємо, у що розвинеться далі цей проєкт.
Але ми далі продовжуємо...
Нас і всіх, хто долучається
до цього, тішить це.